[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Justin's
in Washington DC hey Justin what's going
on hey how you doing sir better than I
deserve how can we
help so uh I'm I'm active duty military
um and uh I have a decent amount of
credit card debt along with debt in
general um and I really am trying to
figure out how I can start knocking this
debt off um and and eliminating this um
know because it's become a bit of a
burden and I honestly don't even know
where to start cool how old are
you I'm uh 28 cool how much debt you
got um between uh house credit card
Vehicles we're about uh 350 how much of
that
house uh
290 okay so you got 60,000 how much of
that car
is uh about 30 to 40 okay so you got
30,000 in credit card debt
uh roughly roughly 28 yeah okay all
right wow thanks for your service which
branch you serve in uh I'm currently
Army sir okay cool thank you very much
how long you been in uh I've been in
about six and a half years about long
enough to make this
mess yeah yeah um
unfortunately okay and you're ready for
a change the payments have caught up to
you and you guys are feeling the weight
of these and you want out
yeah yeah what's your household
income um between my wife and I um we're
about a 100,000 great so you make a 100
you owe 60 in this Consumer Debt so the
question is how much margin can we
create to throw extra on the debt and
we're going to follow the debt snowball
method that's the way 10 million people
have followed it it's the same way I got
out of 40 Grand in debt and so you have
how many debts three or is it more than
that total between the car loans and the
credit card is it multiple
cards uh no it just it's One credit card
and honestly I really didn't even want
to get a credit card to begin with uh
fortunately but you know when you become
a homeowner it's one of those things
that where yeah you got to have it as
like a backup plan well a backup plan
would be your own money like having an
emergency fund where you become the
money money would be a backup plan debt
didn't turn out to be a good backup plan
20% interest on 30 grand is a bad plan
for sure yes
absolutely okay so how much are you okay
so we're going to list the debt smallest
largest you have one big credit card one
big car and that's it other than the
house is that it uh yes and I have a one
of my cars is paid off already yeah um
and then I do have a motorcycle uh
that's for alone 10,000 right now okay
all right and what did you say the
household income was again uh we're
about aund a little under 100,000 it's
like 98 in some change okay Justin when
I was exactly your age I filed
bankruptcy that was 30 years
ago about 35 years ago go now um so I
know how it feels to be scared and broke
and um after that I figured out how to
get out of debt and stay out of debt and
I figured out that it was worth it to
sacrifice now I call it live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else the way you're living
life now is all the money comes in all
the money goes back out and there's
nothing left but
stress so we um after each paycheck we
we still pocket about
anywhere from 1,500 to 2,000 a month
after after all our bills if I woke up
in your shoes knowing what I know now
and today I'm a
multi-millionaire because I quit doing
stupid crap or as much I limited the
stupid crap I do right and so what if I
woke up in your shoes I'm going to give
you a real harsh prescription because I
know that the faster you get out of this
mess the faster you're going to actually
become wealthy you see the ratio of
that yes sir okay so
um anyway I would sell my motorcycle
today it's a freaking toy you don't need
it you can get your motorcycle later by
the way I have several things with
wheels and Motors in them now but I
didn't have them when I was broke and so
you live you drive like no one else so
that later you can drive like no one
else you're driving a $330,000 car i'
probably consider selling that and
moving down but if you want to plow your
way through it you got $60,000 worth of
debt and and if you do that at $2,000 a
month that's 30
months right two a half years you're not
you don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant and you don't need to go on
vacation the only time you're in the
inside of a restaurant is if somebody
you love is working there and you're
getting a free
meal and that might be you but I don't
care nobody is going anywhere except
we're getting out of debt we're living
on beans and rice rice and beans we're
going to clean this freaking mess up and
we're never going back in debt again
because if you didn't have any payments
but a house payment right now man you'd
have some money and you deserve to have
some money cuz you have put in your time
serving your country you don't deserve
to be this
broke absolutely
sir now will you this is going to boot
camp that's what I'm doing you hearing
me yeah absolutely and uh so I actually
do have my motorcycle up for sale right
now good you're ahead meion that um
what's it listed foris that it um so
after all the aftermarket stuff I put on
it um I'm trying to sell it for about 10
um and you know yeah so I figured if if
I can get maybe a little bit less maybe
9500 you know I can put yeah you can
cover it or a little bit more and you'd
have 500 to throw with the credit card
chop the credit card up get your wife on
a budget you two sit down and get every
dollar app out it's completely free to
download it and use it it's the number
one budgeting app in the world go check
it out and sit down and lay yourself out
of budget and commit to boot camp for
the next 24 to 30 months and you could
be debt free but the house and then that
sets you up with a lot of money in your
pocket to do a lot of stuff with in
generosity in investing and to begin
paying off your house yeah there's a lot
of sacrifice you can make if 30 months
sounds like a long time let's sell more
stuff let's increase the income let's
get the expenses down create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life